ahora vamos a resolver ecuaciones un
poquito más complicadas aunque tenemos
aquí una ecuación por ejemplo 3 x x + 5
igual a 17 quedaron bonitos dos colores
no el chiste es que esta ecuación no es
como las que estábamos viendo y si aquí
tuviéramos nada más
x + 5 igual a 17 lo podríamos resolver
muy fácil nada más tendríamos que restar
5 de los dos lados del igual o por
ejemplo si nada más tuviéramos 3x y no
estuviera por aquí este 5 entonces
también nada más tendríamos que dividir
entre 3 de los dos lados del igual y
listo ya habríamos resuelto nuestra
ecuación es lo que hemos estado haciendo
en los últimos vídeos pero aquí tenemos
a los dos tenemos tres x nada 5 igual a
17 aquí como que nos estorba este más 5
no entonces ya no podemos resolver esta
ecuación como en el vídeo pasado
bueno pero de todas formas la podemos
resolver ahora para hacerlo lo que yo
propongo es que veamos primero cuál es
el fondo de esta ecuación qué es lo que
nos está diciendo verlo de una forma
tangible y resolverlo no precisamente
con peras y manzanas pero más o menos y
ya después ver lo que significa todo lo
que hacemos en el mundo de las
ecuaciones y del álgebra y entonces
resolver esta ecuación con puras
operaciones y bueno espero que todo
tenga sentido una vez que hayamos
terminado pero bueno empecemos con la
forma tangible de resolver esta ecuación
ok tenemos aquí 3x más 5 igual a 17 que
es lo que eso significa en el fondo pues
aquí este 3 de x lo que significa es que
estamos sumando x tres veces que
entonces tenemos aquí
mas x mas x
esto de aquí es tal cual 3x y después
tenemos aquí unas 5 o sea que estamos
sumando 5 unidades y bueno de hecho
vamos a dibujar cada una de esas
unidades
aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
entonces tenemos 3 x 3 x nada 5 + 5 que
es esto de aquí y tenemos que eso es
igual a 17 y si vamos a poner las 17
cositas gate 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 aquí esta
ecuación es exactamente lo mismo que
esta ecuación de aquí ahora estas dos
cosas son exactamente iguales porque
entonces si nosotros quisiéramos tachar
un objeto por acá tendríamos que tachar
otro objeto por acá para que estas dos
cosas siguieran siendo iguales ok eso es
lo que pasa con las ecuaciones todo lo
que le hagamos a un lado del igual se lo
tenemos que hacer al otro lado del igual
ahora qué cosa podemos hacerle a este
lado del igual para que nos quede tal
cual como lo que nosotros ya conocemos y
sabemos manejar perfectamente o sea para
que nos quede algo así como 3 x igual a
algún otro número por acá y entonces ya
nada más tengamos que dividir entre 3 de
los dos lados del igual y obtengamos x
muy fácilmente
pues lo que nos estorban son estos
objetos entonces a nosotros nos gustaría
llegar y tachar estos objetos y que
desaparecieran y entonces nada más nos
quedarán estas tres equis pero todo lo
que le hagamos a este lado se lo tenemos
que hacer a este lado entonces aquí si
tachamos cinco objetos tenemos que
tachar por acá otros cinco objetos ok
uno dos tres cuatro cinco y listo esto
de aquí es igual a esto de acá porque
tachan la misma cantidad de objetos de
los dos lados bueno y eso algebraica
mente que signifique pues si quitamos
cinco objetos de este lado podríamos
pensar que estamos restando cinco ok
pero también quitamos otros cinco
objetos de este lado entonces por aquí
también restamos cinco y si hacemos
estas operaciones pues nos queda tres
3 por equis y aquí nos quedan las 5
menos 5 y eso es igual a 0 o sea 3 x + 0
que lo puedo poner o puedo no ponerlo da
lo mismo
ok entonces nos deshicimos como
queríamos de este 5 y ahora sí vamos a
obtener una ecuación de esas que ya
sabemos resolver pero pues esto no nos
sorprende tanto no sea porque lo vimos
aquí teníamos 13 x 15 unidades cinco
objetos tachamos los objetos y pues lo
que nos quedó es simplemente 3x y está
3x que entonces 3x es igual y aquí
podemos hacer dos cosas uno es hacerlo
aritméticamente tenemos 17 menos 5 eso
es igual a 12 o podemos regresarnos a la
forma visual de nuestra ecuación y ver
que aquí teníamos 17 objetos y tachamos
5 objetos y podemos contar cuántos
objetos nos quedan
quedan 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 y
ahora si esta es una ecuación que
sabemos perfectamente cómo resolver
tenemos aquí x su coeficiente 3 entonces
nosotros sabemos que nada más tenemos
que dividir entre 3 de los dos lados del
igual porque este 3 se va a cancelar con
este 3 ahora visualmente que es lo que
estamos haciendo pues estamos dividiendo
estas dos cosas en tres pedazos iguales
ok pero bueno aquí tenemos estos objetos
que ya habían estallado entonces yo digo
que los tenemos que borrar para que no
nos estorben y ahora si queremos dividir
estas cosas en tres pedazos iguales que
íbamos a partir aquí y aquí y entonces
tenemos nuestros tres pedazos iguales y
aquí queremos partir estos dos objetos
en tres pedazos iguales entonces
partimos aquí y aquí ya tenemos nuestros
tres
partes iguales y entonces nosotros
sabemos que cada uno de estos pedazos va
a ser igual a estos pedazos que tenemos
que x es igual
uno dos tres cuatro
y algebraica mente por acá tenemos que
multiplicar por 3 y luego dividir por 3
es como no hacer nada entonces nos queda
x igual a 12 entre 3 pues es igual a 4
ok
x es igual a 4 y pues obviamente
obtuvimos lo mismo que con la ecuación
desarrollada de esta forma que x es
igual a 4 bueno ahora vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio no vamos a escribir todos los
números como objetos de esta forma pero
espero que no te des que estamos
aplicando el mismo tipo de procesos
bueno vamos a hacer una ecuación
ligeramente más complicada 17 x menos 2
iguala
y sabes que vamos a hacer que las
cuentas no queden perfectas para que
haya fracciones y toda la cosa entonces
vamos a poner por aquí menos diez aquí
está ligeramente más complicado pero
nada del otro mundo ya podemos resolver
este tipo de ecuaciones y bueno qué es
lo primero que queremos hacer pues
queremos hacer que este lado de la
ecuación que de una forma más simple o
sea como las de los vídeos pasados donde
tenemos nada más 7x lo sea nos queremos
deshacer de este menos dos y una muy
buena forma de hacerlo es simplemente
sumar un 2 que hay porque entonces menos
dos más dos es igual a cero pero
recordemos que estamos en una ecuación y
si queremos que siga preservando la
igualdad o sea si queremos seguir
diciendo que esto es igual a esta otra
cosa entonces tenemos que sumar por aquí
otro 2
que hay entonces hagamos las cuentas
tenemos aquí 7 x 7 x más menos 2 más 2
pero sé simplemente 0 o sea que podría
poner más 0 o podría no ponerlo da
exactamente lo mismo y eso es igual a
pues aquí tenemos menos 10 más 2 y esto
pues ahora va a parecer un repaso de
suma de números negativos pero a ver
cuánto es menos 10 más 2 pues vamos a
poner la recta numérica no tenemos por
aquí 0 tenemos por aquí 12 y bueno
digamos que tenemos por acá el menos 10
entonces por aquí está menos 9 menos 8
menos 7 y bueno por aquí está en el
resto los números no nada más que pues
no los podemos poner todos que entonces
tenemos menos 10
empezamos en menos 10
y después le sumamos 2 para sumar lo que
hacemos es saltar a la derecha dos
espacios y entonces nos quedamos por
aquí o sea menos 8 aquí es muy
importante recordar esto de la suma de
un número negativo con un número
positivo porque no vaya a ser que nos
equivoquemos y digamos a 10 + 12 12 a
pro tenemos aquí menos 10 entonces
tienen que ser menos 12 no esté menos 10
está por acá y si le sumamos 2 tenemos
que saltar al otro lado de la recta
numérica y entonces nos quedan menos 8
aunque y entonces tenemos que 7x es
igual a menos 8 y ahora si ya tenemos
una ecuación como las que sabemos
resolver muy bien que entonces lo único
que tenemos que hacer es dividir entre 7
de los dos lados del igual para que este
signo de igual siga teniendo sentido y
entonces cualquier cosa por 7 entre 7
nos queda simplemente esa cualquier cosa
y esto es igual a menos 8 séptimos que
podemos sacar el menos de la fracción y
nos queda así menos 8 séptimos y podemos
escribir lo como una fracción mixta y
entonces nos queda que x es igual a
menos y el 7 cabe una vez dentro del 8 y
nos sobra 1 entonces esto es un entero y
un séptimo y listo ya terminamos